Indiana New York
San Francisco the Philippines
New York Argentina
Tampa Florida
and North Carolina
great
South San Francisco
India Nigeria
all over the U.S and the smattering of
people from around the world welcome
okay
great
and we'll be going in just a moment
but asked him
and here's Greg
bye
Greg
hello
got you
and
you're going
all right we are recording and
want to welcome you Greg and I want to
welcome everyone yeah
I want to welcome everyone to the uh
career overview uh this is a session
about why you should pursue a career in
data science we will be talking about
one of the
data science programs and a special
offer for that toward the end of this
session
um the main focus is going to be on
what data science offers you as career
field and I'm going to start by asking a
question of the audience
and this question is just to give us a
baseline of who's in our audience today
and how much experience you have
so if I could ask you to answer that
question and I'll keep this open just
for another 15 seconds or so
and close the poll about five seconds
three two one
okay and about half of our audience or
folks who are still in school
the other half are people who are in the
workforce that gives us a good Baseline
to um
gear our discussion around so
let me introduce myself I'm Stuart Creek
I'm with simply learn where the delivery
partner for this program and I'm here
with Greg White and Greg please
introduce yourself
yeah I've been working
for I know over 30 years and so
with uh everything from heart
when recently kind of trying to watch
data management
and using it to help promote
than those
businesses all of that Greg your audio
is cutting out it's uh every couple
seconds it drops
well I'm gonna let me switch circuits
sorry about that hang on one second sure
pardon me yeah is that better
yeah it seems to be better
okay
the uh
all right one more thing hang on
sure
sorry for the technical difficulty sucks
it's uh
occasionally happens
okay
where's it better now
I think so uh
just go ahead with your introduction
we'll see
um
the the uh the the
dramatically and keeping up with it is
uh
time job these days
areas uh that I've worked it was the
kind of the collecting
immunization
and updated
forms to help to make better decisions
operations more efficiently and so on
actually we simply learned
Cloud courses like Azure and
data data aggregation
and some of the basics for data
like he chose to machine
yeah so uh I've got a lot
quite a few different companies and so
some questions about
uh hiring practices where I know about
job opportunity
kind of path or has our good
pursue especially in
of uh you know fledgling
AI with
and that should be good okay I'm going
to ask you to turn off your videos
because it may be interfering with your
audio
okay maybe having a bandwidth issue
okay I got my video off
it's beginning to sound better
let me see
okay
um so yeah so you're you were saying
that the field of data science has
changed a great deal and we're entering
kind of New Frontiers right
uh
whole area of data science
um palatable
decision makers where they weren't
always
focused on that aspect because they
that that's
a lot of businesses do they still can be
in terms of what the latest
uh the example I'll give you guys is a
chat
taking over things
that's a direct relationship to
big data processing and so on and it's
a lot of companies
um
in the whole topic
okay so here's some information I pulled
together
on you know where did data science come
from as a field and you know
it came out of
people studying things like probability
and uh
the philosopher plays Pascal was kind of
wondering where
uh the probability of a dice game would
go and came up with uh
is the distribution
pyramid and
that kind of thing turned into
be
understanding of probability
distributions and probabilities started
going into
how to
predict
events based on probabilities and then
things like correlation regression
analysis variance
which allow you to
pull the best predicted values out of a
data set
involved in the 1800s the 1900s of
course rapid development of
statistical methods and other tools so
now we're here in the 20th century
and we Now understand you know with
what data can tell us but from that
we've
moved on into some
more advanced issues about machine
learning and
uh
machine intelligence
and you know part of the job of data
science is to be able to
turn statistics into presentations into
information
that's accessible to people that has an
interesting history doesn't it Greg
yeah your your audio is cut out
completely
I'm gonna while you're working on that
I'm gonna to go through you know this
kind of History did you not hear me no I
did not hear you you can hear you now
though
okay yeah I was just agreeing with you
that's a big area of focus these days
with with uh a lot of the verticals
within the business that are separately
trying to determine what's the best way
to statistically analyze all the the
past Behavior so they can plan and
predict future Behavior so I just
agreeing with you on that yeah yeah and
and you know the history of then taking
the information presenting it it's also
really important and
this this example at the top right is
one of the most famous examples probably
the first uh real infographic that shows
data in a visual form what it plots out
is
size of Napoleon's Army as it goes into
Russia and from
left to right is the geography of Russia
uh with the rightmost point being Moscow
and the width of the colored stripes on
the
graph are
size of the army and you can see as it
goes from left to right on its margin
into Russia it gets much smaller
and then from its March from uh right to
left in the black bar
it continues to get smaller and smaller
and smaller
and the notations on the
bars indicate you know the dates at
which these places and sizes occurred so
this was one of the probably the best
um
examples of how to show
relationship between
data and information
it's one thing to say
here are the numbers it's another thing
to see it visually and see
how this Grand Army just
got absolutely wiped out
from this campaign so
it's a
it inspired generations of people to
come up with ways to visualize data and
the rest of this history talks about
um
the actual processing of data and using
data for things like
uh economic modeling and that type of
thing so
now we're in a position where
um
we've moved beyond the use of data for
statistical analysis for
predictive and prescriptive statistics
which is still as Greg pointed out a
really important field and we're getting
into things like machine learning and AI
so it's a
we're in a fantastic time
yeah yeah I'll add that by saying that
this is an area that a lot of people
have been very interested in learning
what the new tools are experimenting
with different ways of presenting the
information in a very Visual and
absorbable way another thing I'll add
real quickly is that a a government
Target for a lot of businesses just to
get a snapshot of what's going on in the
very visual mode to the executive so
they can absorb it in less than 30
seconds so that'd be something else I'll
add it's not like you just whack it into
a graph you want to take some time with
the colors right get the components on
the graph right so the executive student
can very quickly make decisions with it
that's one of the big goals of this
whole field
and looking at real-time dashboards for
executives is
you know a subset of that that's so
important
um so we're at a point now where
more than ever in history data drives
our economy our economy is
almost fundamentally digital today
and
um
you know the volume of data that's being
produced is
stunning uh coming not only from our
activities our transactions our business
operations coming from the internet of
things right
yeah that's another area that I can I
can add in the iot internet things or
iot is something that's relatively easy
to get involved with there's devices
that you can acquire for very low sums
of money 10 to 15 Pi devices things like
that that will let you experiment with
these little small devices that are just
accumulating data at a ridiculously
rapid weight rate and now the challenge
is to process all that data visualize it
and make it useful
yeah and you know if you think about
one example of the internet of things
and in the data science relating to it
you think about a car
with a
wide array of different sensors that
talk about its operation that look
outward at the environment that it
operates in
um the ability for the car to sense
for example Lane drift and take you back
into your lane
um is based on
the data science behind pattern
recognition
uh from the set of sensors that looks at
Lane markers uh self-driving cars of
course are the culmination of that where
data from the sensors turns into
intelligently
um corrected
decisions about driving the car turning
the car accelerating decelerating
so that's one aspect and then the other
aspect is all of that data can be made
available
by Uplink to
aggregators that are going to look at
the aggregate behavior of your of cars
on the road or the the individual
behavior of your car and monitoring it
for uh anomalies from the engine sensors
that type of thing being able to
send you messages about when it's time
to get some part of your car serviced or
looked at not just based on the calendar
but based on what the actual sensors are
telling us
um
our dashboard lights can be
you know simple electronic circuits but
they can also be
based on
sophisticated data analysis and data
science behind that so
we look at
business analytics and dashboards for
executives we look at data science for
um
industrial applications for Internet of
Things type of real world applications
for artificial intelligence machine
learning so we're looking across a whole
spectrum of digital of data science
applications
uh
what kinds of things have you
encountered in your career
Greg
um well the the whole data acquisition
from the from kind of A to Z some of the
first things I encountered were
companies that were accumulating so much
data they didn't know what to do with it
they didn't have a place to put it so
part of the whole data science piece is
where are you going to put all this
information all this data so solving
that challenge is usually a first step
then trying to imagine What's called the
life cycle of data it's another piece of
that because even for a data scientist
you need to know how fresh is your data
how are you how are you making sure your
data is current you're not skewing your
results by looking at outdated
information you're looking at data
that's specific to today and then what
kind of algorithms would you use to try
to pull the most meaningful results out
of that that information and businesses
will spend quite a little a lot of money
and build teams of people
that would be focused on solving these
problems but it's definitely not an
overnight thing the exciting part is
there's a lot of entry-level jobs in
that in that space because it's a new
hopefully new area of Technology not a
lot of people are good at it yet yeah
and you know here's a one
kind of way to think about the process
of how data is
used in
and how data scientists facilitate that
so
data engineering
that acquisition process the data
analysis model development can you take
us through these steps from your
perspective Greg
yeah sure in terms of the the steps
you've got them all laid out at the top
there from data engineering all the way
to the Target of insights and
visualization on the far right there the
data engineering is covered in
database administrators people who do
database programming that will allow you
to do data ingestion component and a big
part of that first block there is making
sure you know not only where your data
is but how how clean the data is how
useful it is and how pertinent is to
your your job so data scientists need to
understand this aspect as well because
otherwise you're analyzing data that
might not be relevant so understanding
the ingestion process the transformation
of the data into a useful set of data
that can be processed by the next stages
like data analysis model development and
so on is a very very important and
somewhat time-consuming area of this but
you definitely have to understand that
that first section and then the same
thing with data and Analysis you learn
basic tools learn at high level find
this guy views of your data and then
allow the drill down to more and more
relevant amount of information to get
the decision-making process and directly
related that is as you're looking at the
data your mind starts saying well how
can I reproduce this how can I create a
model to re repeat this information and
take data that's just related but not
necessarily the same in my model and I
go through it I'll spend a lot of time
modeling my my data output changing the
algorithms changing the number of times
I review my data and so on all those
first three steps are covered in a big
data that kind of a
environment but data scientists have to
have their finger on the pulse and all
that because they're the ones they're
going to take it to the next step which
is ml engineering machine learning
engineering and begin taking and
building models running up in Google
Cloud running in the AWS wherever you're
going to actually run your analysis and
come up with the model the view the
models see how accurate it is and then
turn that into something that's going to
be valuable the final step which is one
or more styles visualization whether
they're real-time visualization batch
jobs that run for hours or even days and
that and it provides insight to your
environment so each one of these steps
is important the data science is rolling
your sleeves that really begins mostly
in love development and onward that's
where all the statistics and Mathematics
and kind of experience in using the
different uh libraries that are
available to help you with this
could produce the output the chicken of
Desire
so that's a that's a great insight and
and it's not a bright line between you
know the data engineering and Analysis
and then data science starts because
data engineering and Analysis are you
need to understand those foundations in
order to be able to understand how to
um
get further insights out of the data so
you really have to to
you know have the broad base of skills
and we'll talk about that in a minute so
here's some interesting quotes that we
found out of uh
various Business Leaders about data
science so
you know Eric Schmidt the chairman of
Google
um there were five exabytes of
information created between the dawn of
civilization through 2003
but now we create five exabytes of
information every two days
um so from
a record of you know took us 10 000
years to get to the first five and then
now we're we're doing that in two days
so yeah that that one right there if I
could jump in that that right there um
of all these you know the first time I
read that kind of statistic it's kind of
hard to believe it was only 10 years ago
you were talking about creating lots of
data in a month or something and now
it's in in days it's it's ridiculous
ridiculous and you should feel sorry for
the people have to figure out where to
put all that yeah right right well and
and it's interesting because if you look
at product announcements from decades
past and you
go on Google and look at you know first
hard drive uh you'll see a stock photo
of
an IBM 5 megabyte hard drive being
delivered it's the size of a
refrigerator
um and
I myself worked on a
10 megabyte hard drive that was the size
of a dishwasher and
program it so that the
arm with the magnetic heads on it would
if you wanted to to be funny you could
program it so that it would move one way
slowly and the other way quickly and you
can make the thing walk across the floor
so
um but
then you see you know if you look at the
initial announcements for things like
MP3 players or
players I'm sorry
um the first audio players that
assessors the iPod and you talk about
how 16 megabytes the articles about that
will talk about how many songs that is
how incredible it is if you look at the
you know
the history of removable storage and
floppy disk drives and
CDs CD-ROMs and DVD ROMs
um you see the the rapid acceleration of
the process
and now a thumb drive with uh
close to a terabyte of data on it is
something you can order from Amazon yeah
but
the exponential increase in the
capability of the technology
and and the cultural acceptance of
how much data
we're all dealing with
really amazing
people
uh
casually throw away or throw around the
terms gigabyte terabyte today
um which would have no meaning to the
general public 30 years ago
yeah I honestly probably still doesn't I
a point about that first quarter should
make is that one of the challenges that
the Google chairman was referred to
there the information uh being created
doesn't mean that that all that
information is necessarily being stored
so the people who are in this you know
Big Data data scientists and so on uh in
in order to compre in order to handle
that they're not building a new data
center every two days that's not
realistic one things they're doing is
becoming more aggressive about
information management information like
psychopath tagging it archiving it cold
storage unit and still being able to use
it for analytics when they need to so
that's that that first statement there
again it's just a lot of opportunity for
people who want to dig into how do I
deal with large amounts of data and if
you don't mind I can I want to just
segue into that second quote there
yeah the the the the information has
always been the big main driver of a lot
of businesses and so that's it but the
this the court saying that the analytics
of the conductor mentioned the thing
that runs it analytics is the area
that's getting a huge amount of
attention right now so becoming
proficient and talking about the basics
and the core principles is a really
great driver for people trying to move
into this field which is very lucrative
very important because they want to hear
how do I analyze that all that data and
what kind of engines are there are there
like little tiny two-cylinder engines or
they're turbocharged V8 uh what what
kind of engines how do they work and how
do I pick which one I want to use so
that second quote there is driving a
huge amount of of Education of skills
development and utilization within
business across the board I'll throw it
back to you but I just wanted to to make
a big point that someone who knows how
to work on a car engine
is important someone who knows what
analytics and analytics engine is is
just as important if not more
it also suggests you know tying the two
coats together the the model of uh
natural resources we talk about uh Data
Mining and we talked about knowing what
data to keep and what to discard is very
much like what happens in the process of
mining or you pull out a ton of Earth
filter through it and you find the
useful part
which may be a few pounds out of that
ton
and that's where the value is and that's
what you keep in
and so information is the oil the 21st
century analytics is a combustion engine
just
you really you
even the term data mining which is a a
term of the art
reflects the idea of
looking for the value within all of that
sea of
raw data so
um and and that leads to the next
quotation which is you know we're
surrounded by data but we're starved for
insight so
that's really
kind of doesn't that kind of sum up what
data science is about right
yeah that that's a these are all really
good quotes and by the way these are
good quotes for you guys to you know
screenshot or something like that and
have them at your your fingertips when
someone says what is it that you do or
what is it that you're you're working on
being able to do and one of them is that
the understanding that we are are
surrounded by data well what kind of
data where is it located and how do we
how do we take a look at it knowing a
couple of examples of how to do that
third quote there how to show an Insight
dashboard is a really good thing to be
able to do
yeah
um
and that's the reason why data
scientists paid
a a really nice salary that
they're the people who who mediate
between raw data and the useful
information and the insights you can get
from it and and that takes us to the
last quote which is data is a tool for
enhancing intuition
um and that
takes us out of the era of you know I I
trust my gut and I do everything by gut
instinct two I trust the data and I
trust what it is telling me about what's
happening in the real world and how
people are actually behaving so
um
where's the past
you could use intuition purely uh to
guide your your activities your business
today you have the ability to use data
and
if you're not using the data you're
missing a huge competitive advantage and
you may be leading yourself into a
destruction of your business
if you go with your gut instead of going
with what the data is actually telling
you so
um this is why yeah that's that's
another yeah
sorry no go ahead that's another really
good point that's another really good
point is that a lot of businesses uh I
can either travel since I worked on that
for a while they need to understand what
changes are happening almost in real
time in that industry is for example
rental cars they need to know which kind
of which cities are going to have the
highest demand uh are they one way or
two right what kind of pricing should I
do based upon the demand and the
availability in that section all that
information that's readily available if
you screen scrape it if you have data
feeds from other places but how do you
correlate all that so that the big guy
can make a decision on the most
profitable method of managing this
business you don't want to see the pants
that stuff because that could be
millions of dollars in in a differential
in in revenue and profit so that's a
huge part of this and that's something
that you learn as you work with data you
you build up your skill sets in being
able able to look at these Trends
yourself it's a very uh it's almost like
an art form we've got to get started
though with data and the data science
portion of it to get good at it
um it's worth knowing some of the
numbers that the data science platform
Market spending on
all of the infrastructure in the
services to to process data
to analyze data to to get those insights
out of it it's a 25 compound annual rate
which is
the nominal exponential growth and we're
looking to see the total Market
worldwide for platforms
within 10 years will be over a trillion
dollars trillion almost a trillion and a
half
so this is this is a field where
opportunities are following that
acceleration investment
yeah if I could add it to that too I
brought it up earlier but the whole the
whole interest in the application of
this organized structured data is
feeding us into the whole era of machine
learning and AI so just to get an
example that most of everybody on the
call has probably seen the AI components
are now built in for Microsoft Bing
there's applications you can load on
your on your uh mobile device it'll give
you very sophisticated Solutions all of
that is being processed out of Big Data
environments that were built by data
scientists software Engineers to
understand how to pull all that
information together to make it useful
so that's if anybody's wondering well
what what is it why is the sport and the
white side to it that that is your end
result it's very basic right now
but it's because it's becoming
sophisticated very quickly and therefore
the man the people who understand what's
going on and how to enhance it is also
growing very quickly so I just wanted to
throw that out there that there's
definitely drivers out there that are
pushing this whole area kind of at my
speed right now yeah
so that leads us into talking about
you know the growth in careers I mean
the the
current number for number from the U.S
Bureau of Labor Statistics so they say
that they're a hand
that's going to grow
substantities being created
every year
it's a
a growing field and these
jobs the correspond to a bunch of
openings that don't get filled right
away right
yeah well the thing is here as well is
getting when you first go into a
business and you're going to be working
in their I.T department or whatever
Department you're aiming at and a lot of
times the people that are doing this
kind of work are separate from the I.T
Department those guys are keeping the
computers running the storage devices
and the networks working and all that
typically there's a separate little
group of people who used to be database
administrators or work with stored
procedures and work on the database side
that that group typically has expanded
to be a little army of kind of analysts
and there's a lot of uh entry-level
uh work there that will help you kind of
achieve this high growth factor that
businesses are going to demand over the
next two years doing several of the jobs
in that big chart we saw earlier so you
understand the nuances of each one foot
you're more efficient when you get to
the point where you're the person
responsible for building that very
meaningful anal analytics output for one
of these companies that you see here so
like Boeing or Granger or Olympus
Walmart I mean I haven't worked for very
many of these personally but I have
worked for a lot of big telecoms some of
the manufacturing companies and they
absolutely care that you go into a
meeting
a lot of times they don't know you know
exactly how to proceed so you want to be
kind of Broad in your knowledge your
ability to talk about these topics and
your understanding so that you can make
an impact on a on a company that you're
going to hopefully be working According
to some of the data scientists related
work
and it's interesting this is just a
snapshot from
The Glassdoor and looked at the uh
openings for data science and these were
some of the top companies that came up
yeah but you can see it cuts across all
different industries from Nova Nordisk
is a pharmaceutical company
Granger is the supply chain for
um maintenance supplies
um Olympus of course is uh the camera
and Optics uh in sensor company USAA
Insurance Walmart
retailing Apple uh high-tech devices for
consumers Boeing Aerospace add
services to business all of these
companies
in all of these disparate areas have
needs for data scientists to be able to
help them understand their supply chain
to understand uh the behavior of their
products the behavior of the consumers
um
to look for
new products based on the data they have
about existing products
um
all of this is
a fascinating area you can pick and
choose to a certain extent what sector
you want to go into and what kinds of
applications you want to work on
and we talk about the fact that it's a
lucrative field
these are average USA salaries different
uh job classifications so you can see at
the entry level if you're a senior data
analyst
and you're being asked to use your data
science skills to look at you know the
you know what is happening in your your
company or market today what will happen
in the future
you can follow that track from 84k
toward the entry level to
top salary of you know 156 according to
Glassdoor
um if you move up your skill set to data
scientist
to look at you know more of the meta
questions around that
now you're on a track that's at a higher
trajectory and if you move farther away
on that if you want to pursue
um gaining more skills over time and
moving into uh machine learning
artificial intelligence and
higher levels of work in that area you
can
look at a much higher trajectory as well
so
um
how do people move you know down the
column in a single area or across
diagonally to different areas Greg
yeah well
the uh the entry level prop for probably
most people on this call with the main
thing for almost all those jobs the
entry levels with senior data analysts
or something at the lower level get your
feet wet and so if your goal is to get
up to the highest levels of this chart
then you want to get into a position
where you like I said you're able to
talk about it speak about it right about
the technology so that you can
communicate with your peers with your
management with your customers if you're
in that kind of a business and the
better you are at communicating and
thinking through problems being
completely comprehensive making
PowerPoint displays about how did they
go about doing something the more
rapidly you will typically move up to
these levels because one of the big
problems of this whole area is
communication because there's a lot of
unknowns and people will look at you
glazed over like what are you even
talking about so one of the other skills
is as you're going through your training
and you're learning is to make sure that
you can take what you're learning and
get rid of all the buzzwords a lot of
time and put it into English so even
though that might be a little bit more
work for you it's a very good for your
career all those top salary ranges if
you can't communicate you probably won't
get there you've got to be able to to
communicate what you're doing why you're
gonna do it why you need this big budget
why you need all these different Tools
in order to progress and it's relatively
easy to do starting in the entry level
if that's your goal so my recommendation
is as you're going through training to
make notes of whatever's going on in a
notebook somewhere in English so that
you can then explain to somebody else
what it is that you're doing that's my
probably my biggest uh piece of advice I
give to even all the people who's ever
worked for me is go practice that
practice on each other practice on your
peers etc etc
yep
um
there's a bunch of different tools that
data scientists use and
they're depending on what specialization
you're going to go into what particular
area you're going to you may use
some of these more than others
but the
thing that we want to emphasize here is
that it's important
to have a broad background that allows
you to understand what these tools are
for how to use them and where to apply
them because knowing this
will give you the ability then to
um
move
through that salary table that we just
showed you python scripting language in
the various libraries that do the
analytics and Python and the
visualization so
numpy scipy met plotline and pandas are
all
basic tools that you use for
manipulating data through python
and so that's one aspect of it and then
you have these other tools
that get you into
um
other aspects so SQL for understanding
data management
um elearn for machine learning are for
sophisticated uh
data analysis it's a very powerful tool
for data science
Tableau for visualization
tensorflow for deep learning uh and and
mind mapping that's that's a relates
directly to what you were saying Greg
about
um communication and being able to take
what it is a uh
business or a customer wants and turning
it into something something that
everyone can understand right
yeah exactly I I will I almost of all
those tools that are on there I've
probably touched almost all of them but
the one I I started with years ago that
I used almost all the time was mind
mapping so mind mapping is a revelation
to a lot of people when you show people
a mind map when you're running a meeting
by using a mind map to capture all the
information to display it back that
whole communication thing I mentioned is
extremely easy to demonstrate using a
mind mapping tool at some level of skill
so my other strong suggestion is if when
you take the course on the data science
have a mind mapper tool available to you
so you can mind map everything that
you're learning because two months three
months a year from now it'll make it all
a lot more meaningful to you it's but
it's a super charged way of writing
things down but it's also a supercharged
way of explaining and showing things to
other people and there's a lot of
different tools that are free out there
the sums are paid but I would I would
use that tool first of all the pools
that are on there and then I would
probably make sure I knew how to use
MySQL pretty well because it's very
basic and for from the visualization
perspective it's easy to get started
with power bi probably start that and
then I might go do a demo of Tableau
which is super hot right now so there's
all these other tools are definitely
have a niche but being able to talk
about the ones I just said and python
for development by the way would be the
place I would recommend focusing your
your time to get at least somewhat
proficient that
and I just put a reminder in the chat by
the way I want to ask questions of Greg
put those in the Q a and we'll also be
telling you about
the um
we'll be telling you about the bonus
a little bit after the Q a session so
uh I'm Gonna Leave This up
because uh Zoom kind of messes with me
when I do a
when I stop sharing a reshare so I'm
going to leave this slide up but uh
apologize for that
um but let's take some questions and
again
if you've got additional questions
please put those into the chat for us
because I'd like to uh you have two
questions in there in the Q a right now
let's get more
um
will the recorded version of this
webinar be sent to us you will receive a
follow-up email after this webinar it
will contain a link to this recording
it will contain details about the bonus
offers that you get for attending
and mention more about that later
um
so we had a question Greg can you get
more insight into the model development
and ml engineering aspects of data
science
yeah the the uh there's a lot of
there's a lot of existing libraries that
are incorporating some of the algorithms
and the models that are used for
different aspects of business like for
in a course setting a lot of weather
analysis is one to predict whether uh
cash flow analysis to look at the the
way that your products are being selling
by Geo area my geographic area or by
consumer demographic and things like
that those are the types of things that
are useful to talk about whether one
because everybody gets it right so
whether you don't have to explain what
that is but if you want to if you talk
to a business person being able to
explain one of the models that is used
in the e-commerce area or sales and
manufacturing area that will pique the
interest of the people who are going to
write the checks to buy the second stack
and to hire you and to get the world
moving so knowing why don't you'll pick
one that you like like rather uh and
then pick another one that's more
business oriented and be able to talk
about them go online look at some of the
examples specific type of models because
there's a lot of specific models covered
in the course and you can choose which
one you want to become really good at
don't try to be good at all of them
because you can't really do that right
away be good become good at some things
that you want to be able to talk about
in a you know a business setting or
something like that I strongly encourage
you practice your verbal skills your
written communication skills to do that
because that's very impressive the
people that you're trying to get to hire
you right and
that kind of ties together with the next
question from Andre which is you know
what are the main data analysis
techniques currently used in business
and how
can they um
helping in making strategic business
decisions
um and before you answer that Greg I'm
going to um
comment on I can't rattle off the
yeah I would like to watch the main ones
yeah but uh
to analytics falls into to basically
three main categories there's
descriptive statistics
uh
there's predictive statistics and
there's prescriptive statistics and so
the the analysis techniques the
different types of
um
probability curve fitting and that type
of thing and understanding where the um
uh how the data is shaped
um and what
particular
probability distributions to apply to it
um and other types of techniques
that is one aspect of analysis and then
what you're going to use the analysis
for are you are you trying to describe
what has happened in the past and what
is happening now
uh with descriptive statistics so that
you can say this is this is what we saw
in our sales pattern for example in the
last year
or are you looking to do predictive
statistics where you must say Okay based
on what we've seen in the past and
present this is what we expect our sales
to do in the future
the next two quarters for example
or are you looking at prescriptive
statistics where you start doing what if
analysis that says okay if we take this
particular action what is likely to
happen to our our future sales
those are kinds of those are three of
the classifications and with within the
types of techniques used
um you know it varies on what aspect
you're focusing on
you need to be able to um
understand what pattern the data fits
you need to be able to make probable
probability inferences from the data you
need to be able moving into machine
learning to look at
how the data can be classified so that
you can draw future
influence inferences from it in a better
way so looking at the different machine
learning models that you might apply to
data being able to pick the right one in
order to create a machine learning
system that will look at new data fit it
in in the correct way so that your
decisions become better over time and
all of this is to say that you know all
intended to support
um either business decision making if
it's business analysis or to support
um
things like real-time control of systems
if you're looking at physical real world
data and trying to
figure out how to make a
self-driving car behave that type of
thing all of that
Bill draws a fundamental on
the fundamental level on the statistical
analysis and then
different extents on the different types
of machine learning
whether it's
algorithmic or whether it's deep
learning
and then on into artificial intelligence
so
I hope that answers that question how
can people like us
we're just coming in without the
background
would have basic Computing how do we
penetrate this market and we're actually
going to talk about that in just about a
minute
um
about a program that will help you do
that
that's a really good segue right now
that takes us to our last question so
I'm going to go ahead and move on
but feel free to email us if you have
additional questions I'm going to drop
into the chat before I start this poll
a
email address
contact us about
your questions and about the course that
we're going to describe so let me put
that in the chat for you
we got a couple questions in the chat
let me see if we can look at those
uh
any advice for developers moving from
web towards starting a career in data
science
that we'll be talking about that in just
a moment
um
you know most of these chat questions
we'll be we'll be talking about in just
a second
so again I apologize if we haven't
gotten to them directly but
let's start this poll
and
oops wrong way
there's the button
so I'm going to ask what has stopped you
up until now from
pursuing a data science certification
taking a course that would get you into
this field
and I'll leave this open for just about
another 10 seconds you can pick one two
three or all four of these
get those answers in hit the submit
button in three
two
one
and I'm going to end the poll now
share with you the results and the main
concerns people in our audience have
today is uh
having practical experience coming out
of a program to be able to demonstrate
your new skills and also finding the
time to fit this into your work schedule
so with that let's talk about
one of the programs that simply learn
offers with Caltech
Center for technology management
education there provides a data science
boot camp we're the delivery partner
which means that we provide the digital
platform that our Learners use and
Caltech designed this curriculum to be
able to teach data science to people who
are fairly novice and
talk about the requirements but it's
pretty straightforward it's very open
and it gives in six months a good
foundation for understanding data
science and where you can go in the
industry so it gets your job ready
for your entry level jobs but it also
gives you the foundation you'll need go
forward so there's a comprehensive
curriculum coverage a whole wide range
of skills and tools
lets you use those skills and tools
Hands-On in online Labs but it's all
through one learning environment an
online learning environment that you
access on your desktop or laptop
you don't have to download anything you
don't have to um
installed new software in your system
you can do it all through a virtual
environment that's provided to you
and it includes online live classroom
instructions so that you can uh get your
answers directly from your instructor
they can quiz you they can take you
through live examples
um so that it's not just a matter of
watching videos and trying to replicate
what you've just seen it's a matter of
uh getting that live coaching and
instruction on a weekly basis with your
with your instructors outside of those
live classes which are usually scheduled
uh Saturday and Sunday mornings in the
US
you have the ability to do all the other
work the projects uh
pre-study for the the upcoming class
review of all the materials uh all of
that's available 24 7. so you can do
that on anytime that you find that you
have available
talk about about 10 hours a week of
dedicated effort uh we'll get you
through this boot camp so
where we think that it's something that
will fit everybody's schedule
uh Greg can you help me come through
this
curriculum and
make a couple of comments yeah sure
uh so yeah
yeah the the this curriculum is pretty
powerful to answer the questions of how
do I get started first thing I want to
say about how do I get started is that
fortunately this kind of a a job it
doesn't necessarily require you going
understanding you know physical Hardware
networking operating systems and all of
that that's that was the entry Bar for a
lot of jobs just a few years ago in this
job it's not really an understanding of
business and business requirements that
you can get by reading various books on
business is one way another way is just
to jump in and start working with
different kinds of data smaller amounts
of data learn how to manipulate it learn
how to analyze it so that first couple
of layers there orientation statistics
Essentials for data science covers a lot
of that so you'll learn okay here's my
data set here's like how I can analyze
it here's a result I might real I might
be able to get once you've got those
basics down and your book you're
comfortable with taking an Excel
spreadsheet or a database and turning it
into something useful you go up to that
next bar which is applied science with
python and machine learning and there
you go with which language should I use
well there's the answer right there
python python is probably the most
widely used language in this field of
all the languages the other language
that's used is Java but it's a lot more
difficult to learn a pretty good sized
learning curve and then R for the more
dedicated focused data scientist but to
Learn Python is a very smart move so no
matter what go do that then machine
learning there's a lot of different
exercises that you can execute during
the classes themselves that will have
you go through different types of data
use the use the various tools that are
available both Standalone and in the
cloud will help you create and build
these machine learning
modules that will let you train the
model against your data produce results
and so on and then the last step is
understanding with one or more tools how
to visualize it Tableau by far is
probably the most popular visual
visualization tool out there power bi as
I mentioned is another very popular one
from Microsoft so learn a couple of
visualization tools then jump up that
Capstone project and the Capstone
project will have you exercise all of
the different things that you've learned
at the end of the entire program so that
you've got something you can talk about
even in an interview you can say I've
done this type of analysis here's what I
use for my Capstone project I work with
the trainer with my fellow students and
this is what the problem was how we
approached it and how we solved it great
story to tell someone that you are
interviewing with for a job yeah and
that's that's a great aspect of the
program is that the Capstone project and
all the other projects you do along the
way end up in your get portfolio
something that you can then point people
to and have them see the actual
practical examples that you've done the
work that you've done and how you've
done it
um exactly exactly and doing that in an
interview is not a bad thing you offer
and say I'd like to show you here's my
git repository here's the documentation
I wrote up here's the result here's how
it works very very powerful if you can
wedge that into an interview yeah uh the
electives as you mentioned Greg are
included in the in the program at no
extra cost so based on each learner's
you know level of interest in the amount
of time they wanted to vote they can
take these uh electives and we
especially recommend the Caltech data
science master classes which uh you know
periodically through the program you're
getting access to folks from Caltech who
will take you into some of the really
fascinating projects they've done
you know one of the program directors
from Caltech likes to mention
that um
one of their astrophysics researchers
believe she won the Nobel Prize for
visualizing a black hole
and and the idea is that you get an
awful lot of interesting data out of
radio telescopes and
other Spencers that look at the deep
space around us but
what does that
sensor data tell you really and what
physical phenomena describing and so
that was a really huge exercise
in data science and artificial
intelligence to come up with what does
this data tell us about the physical
structure of a black hole and how can we
visualize it to look at you know get in
the surrounding space
so it's an amazing
another illustration of how data science
works and these are the types of people
that you can hear from in the master
classes but I talked about this being a
really open program
um it really is it's open to anyone
who's 18 years of age or older as a high
school diploma I'm going to presume that
of people in our audience get that
qualification
you do have to have some knowledge of
programming Concepts and Mathematics
Concepts so you do want to have you know
things like college math
um some base you know basic uh dabbling
in programming you do not have to be a
programmer by profession you do not have
to be from a technical background we do
prefer that you have some work
experience so it's best if you've been
in the Working World for some time and